[Music]
a tennessee man is building a brighter
and more connected community one
step at a time sean dromgool is a
long-time resident of his nashville
neighborhood known as 12
south after the death of george floyd he
posted to social media saying he was
afraid to walk alone because of the
color of his skin
our jamie wack shows us his
neighborhood's moving response
sean drumgool is no stranger to the view
outside his nashville home
the 30 year old has lived in the
neighborhood his entire life
his family for generations growing up it
was a mostly black community
everyone was family and then it changed
as the area grew in popularity sean
watched as his neighborhood became
gentrified
the black families he once played with
moved out and white families moved in
and a few years ago a pivotal turning
point sean says police stopped him
without reason and followed him home
to make sure he lived there
in a time when america is experiencing
nationwide protests over racial
inequality
he didn't feel safe to walk alone down
his street
what was it that made you feel fear
in a neighborhood that your family had
been a part of for 54 years
people saying um it's a suspicious
looking black man
walking down the street if you say
suspicious looking black man the police
come
ready and i'm dead before
i can even think it's a very real fear
as an african-american male
in 2020 as george floyd's story became
embedded in the american conscience
sean posted this i wanted to walk around
my neighborhood but the fear of not
returning home to my family alive
kept me on my front porch 50 people
responded oh my god i'm so sorry oh my
god i'll walk with you and there were 75
people in the parking lot it's like
wow i don't feel invisible i feel like
people care
i will never know what it's like to be
in the shoes of somebody
who has a different color skin than me
carrie conley was one of the neighbors
at the walk
i've lived here 15 years he's literally
like
three and a half blocks from me and i've
never seen him or his family
so it was a big wake-up call for me i
want to show you
the amazing neighbors that are here sean
began hosting
weekly neighborhood walks with hundreds
of strangers coming out to support him
turning it into a movement called we
walk with sean
the goal is simple get to know your
neighbors
when you're walking you're bound to have
conversations and when you have
conversations
you change you learn so that you can be
a positive
effect yeah it was that bridge that's
all that it was for carrie and sean
these one one-time strangers are now
like family
he calls me a sister it seems like i've
known him
my whole life if we don't stop to talk
to our neighbors we're missing out on
on so much we are only getting
started sean hopes he can bring the
movement to many u.s cities
and walk in other gentrified
neighborhoods this is
what happens to black and brown families
who remain in inner city
or suburban neighborhoods it's a bad
feeling
when you feel like you're a prisoner i
was literally felt like i was a prisoner
on my front porch you are sitting on the
steps
that you sat on and were afraid to move
from
how does it feel now i'm now free to
walk around the neighborhood
the whole world is behind me i am
getting to see
america live up to its creed of being a
more
perfect union i'm a part of a story that
begins
on the slave ships and now i get to see
this little part
of the world and become a better place
for cbs this morning jamie wax new york
it's great yeah watching those long
lines of people as i get the walks get
longer every day
and it really puts it in perspective
when you know the end there
you know descendants of slaves and now
here you are walking with
white people black people all kinds of
people and i think that
that walk should be happening more
throughout all neighborhoods in this
country
uh we do have some exciting news by the
way to share about jamie wax who just
did that story
we told you on saturday we're going to
tell you again now we can talk about
this every day because we're so happy
for jamie
he and his wife jacqueline welcomed a
baby girl there she is adelaide simone
wax was born july 30th was talking with
jamie over the weekend
um he sent me a text the day before yeah
going into labor at 10 o'clock i'm like
prayers up good luck could you imagine
all that
happening yeah such a great job at once
congrats man
congrats